of us interpret interpret the possible
ripple effects of Iowa's issues on the
Democratic presidential race we're
joined by CBS News senior political
analyst John Dickerson in Washington
John good morning good morning Anthony
what do you make of Joe Biden's finish
obviously we still are only dealing with
about 70% of the results from Iowa but
Joe Biden went in as theoretically as a
front-runner and looks like he's gonna
finish ahead set a distant fourth yeah
when the remaining 30% come in it's
still probably not going to be very good
for Joe Biden when you're the
front-runner fourth place is just
totally is not good at all the so that's
the bad case is that he just not in the
Iowa conversation in any good way
heading into New Hampshire the good case
potentially for Joe Biden is that you
don't want to be the inevitability
candidate who people just think it's
your turn you want to have to fight for
it and show that you can actually win
votes come back and so he's been knocked
to his knees here and if he then can get
back up he can then say you know I'm a
fighter and I've earned this John and in
polls Democrats routinely say that
somebody who can beat President Trump is
what they're looking for so I wonder
coming out of Iowa do we know anything
more about who's the most electable no
and and and that's one of the great
questions at the center if not the great
question at the center of the Democratic
race they're desperate to beat President
Trump and probably more desperate after
last night's State of the Union which as
much as they dislike it was effective
and they just don't know which route to
take they've decided that the inevitable
and the front-runner Joe Biden in Iowa
they've made a decision that he's not
the route but now the question is
between those two lanes the sort of the
Buddha judge and then the Sanders Warren
Lane and and that might take a good
while to work out let's talk about that
State of the Union John listen first the
president didn't shake her hand that was
seen as a snub she then tour of his
State of the Union speech right behind
him while still on camera what does it
say about the state of politics I know
it's bad but I'm looking at the bigger
picture here what does it say have you
seen anything like it
in history not I mean I don't you know
the Woodrow Wilson started doing it in
person again in night
13 I can't think of an instance in which
it's been this partisan in that room
usually there's a little bubble that
surrounds the president and usually a
president reaches out in that moment
even if they were quite partisan they
reach out to create a little moment of
unity there are areas where there's a
new trade deal in which Nancy Pelosi
actually worked quite hard to get the
president what he wants he could have
taken that opportunity but it was clear
from the moment he walked in and also
when she didn't use the traditional
language to to announce him that this
was going to be as infected a moment as
all the rest of our politics is and that
sets up for a very ugly presidential
campaign and I think people are tired of
that too the tit for tat on both sides
it's something they are tired it is
exhausting and they all want to be
delivered from it and I think that's
part of what you get a little bit in
them in the Buddha judge candidacy is
some of his rhetorical turns represent a
kind of old-style politics in terms of
giving people some kind of hope on the
way out of this can come out of nowhere
I think there's a little bit of that in
his candidacy but people are sick of it
and by the way you can only solve some
of these big problems through collective
action you can't just executive order
your way through them so we are in a fix
some people are looking for a healer
John Dickerson thank you very much